Je vais présenter trois projets en tir rapide.
Je n'ai pas beaucoup de temps pour le faire,
et je veux souligner 3 idées dans cette présentation rapide.
La 1 ière est ce que j'appelle un procédé hyper-rationnel.
C'est une démarche qui
pousse la rationalité à un niveau quasi-absurde
et qui transcende tout le bagage
venant habituellement avec
ce que les gens nommeraient la conclusion rationnelle d'un projet.
Et cela aboutit à ce que vous voyez ici,
quelque chose que vous n'imagineriez pas comme
le fruit de la rationalité.
La deuxième -- (indistinct) euh --
la deuxième idée est que ce processus
ne porte pas de signature.
Il n'y a pas de paternité. Les architectes sont obsédés par la paternité.
Ici il y a du montage et des équipes.
Nous ne voyons plus, dans le cadre de ce processus,
le traditionnel Maître architecte qui crée
une ébauche que réalisent ses larbins.
Et la 3e idée est que ce processus s'attaque -- et c'est,
tout au long, très difficile à justifier,
à faire la synthèse -
mais ce processus défie la notion haut-moderniste de flexibilité.
Les haut-modernistes ont dit: "Nous allons créer
des espaces singuliers qui seront génériques.
Où n'importe quoi peut se passer à l'intérieur."
Pour moi, c'est de la flexibilité de fusil à pompe.
Tournez la tête comme ça, tirez, et c'est sûr que vous allez tuer quelque-chose.
Voici donc la promesse du haut-modernisme:
"À l'intérieur d'un seul espace, tout genre d'activité peut avoir lieu."
Mais, comme nous constatons,
les charges d'exploitation commencent à écraser les coûts d'immobilisation
en termes de paramètres de conception.
Le problème, avec ce genre de conception,
c'est que ce qui se trouve dans le bâtiment le jour de l'ouverture,
ou ce qui semble répondre au besoin le plus pressant,
tend à réduire les choix et donc à subsumer,
la possibilité de toute autre fonction.
Nous proposons donc un autre type de flexibilité,
celle que nous appelons
"la flexibilité compartimentée."
C'est l'idée que, de ce continuum, on
identifie une série de points auxquels la conception va s'adapter précisément.
Les points peuvent être légèrement décalés,
mais en bout de course vous retrouvez toutes les nuances
du spectre initial que vous souhaitiez à l'origine.
Avec la flexibilité haut-moderniste, cela ne marche vraiment pas.
Je vais maintenant parler de -- je vais construire la bibliothèque centrale de Seattle
devant vos yeux, avec cette approche, en 5 ou 6 diagrammes,
et c'est vraiment le processus de conception que vous allez voir.
Avec le personnel et le conseil d'administration de la bibliothèque,
nous avons opté pour deux positions de base.
Voici la première, qui montre, au cours des 900 dernières années,
l'évolution du livre et d'autres technologies.
Ce diagramme était notre déclaration de position en ce qui concerne le livre,
et notre position était que les livres sont de la technologie --
ce que les gens oublient -
mais une forme de technologie qui va devoir partager sa dominance
avec toute autre forme de technologie ou média vraiment puissante.
La deuxième prémisse - avec laquelle nous avons eu beaucoup de mal
à convaincre les bibliothécaires au début --
est que les bibliothèques, depuis le tout début
de la tradition de la bibliothèque Carnegie en Amérique,
ont une seconde responsabilité - celle de leur rôle social.
Bien, je vais y revenir plus tard, mais ce que,
les bibliothécaires nous ont d'abord dit était :"Non, ce n'est pas notre mandat.
Notre mandat, c'est les médias, et surtout le livre."
Ce que vous voyez donc ici est effectivement le dessin du bâtiment.
Le schéma du haut
illustre ce que nous voyons dans beaucoup de bibliothèques contemporaines
utilisant la flexibilité haut-moderniste.
Là où toutes sortes d'activités pourraient se dérouler n'importe où.
"Nous ne connaissons pas l'avenir de la bibliothèque, nous ne connaissons pas l'avenir du livre,
nous adopterons donc cette approche."
Et ce que nous avons vu, c'était des bâtiments très génériques.
Et, pire, non seulement avons nous vu des bâtiments très génériques -
donc non seulement la salle de lecture ressemble à la reprographie
qui ressemble au coin des magazines -
mais cela faisait que tout problème, quoi qu'il soit,
qui préoccupait la bibliothèque à ce moment-là, se mettait à
engouffrer toute autre activité y ayant lieu.
Et en ce cas-ci, ce qui se faisait engouffrer
était ces responsabilités sociales -- par l'expansion du livre.
Nous avons donc proposé ceci, dans le diagramme du bas.
Méthode assez simplette:
compartimenter, et c'est tout. Mettre les choses dont l'évolution était prévisible -
et je ne veux pas prétendre prédire tout ce qui arriverait dans le futur,
mais nous avons un degré de certitude sur l'étendue
des perspectives pour l'avenir -
les placer dans des boîtes conçues spécifiquement à cet effet,
et placer les choses que nous ne pouvons pas prévoir sur les toits.
C'était donc l'idée de base.
Ensuite, nous avons dû convaincre la bibliothèque que la mission sociale
était aussi importante que les médias
afin de les mener à accepter cette proposition.
Ce que vous voyez ici est en effet leur programme, là, à gauche.
Voilà ce que l'on nous a donné, en toute sa clarté et gloire.
Notre première démarche était de la re-digérer,
la rediriger vers eux et dire;
"Hé, vous savez, on ne la pas touché,
mais seulement un tiers de votre propre programme, à vous, est consacré aux médias et aux livres.
Les deux tiers sont déjà consacrés - là, la bande blanche en bas -
ce que vous avez affirmé ne pas être important:
sont déjà consacrés aux fonctions sociales."
Une fois, donc, que nous leur avions présenté tout sous cet angle-ci,
ils étaient d'accord que ce genre d'idée de base pourrait marcher.
Nous avons eu droit de retourner aux principes primaires -
- et c'est le troisième diagramme. Nous avons tout regroupé.
Puis nous avons commencé à prendre des nouvelles décisions.
À droite vous voyez le dessin de la bibliothèque,
spécifiquement en termes de mètres carrés.
Du coté gauche de ce schéma, ici,
vous pouvez voir
une série de cinq plateformes -
comme des alvéoles; des fonctions groupées.
Et du coté droit sont les espaces encore indéterminés,
des salles de lecture par exemple, dont l'évolution
des 20, 30, 40 prochaines années ne peuvent être prévue.
Ceci était donc, littéralement, le plan du bâtiment.
Ils l'ont signé et, à leur grand désenchantement,
nous sommes revenus vers eux une semaine plus tard pour leur présenter ceci.
Bon. Et, comme vous voyez, c'est littéralement le diagramme de droite.
D'accord? Nous avons simplement calibré -
non, sérieusement, je l'entends littéralement.
Les sections du - du côté gauche du diagramme,
ils sont devenus ces boîtes.
Nous avons ajusté cinq compartiments à leur taille.
Ils sont super-efficaces. Nous avons dû travailler avec un budget très serré.
Nous les avons déplacés par-ci par-là sur le site afin de créer
des rapports conceptuels très littéraux.
La salle de lecture devrait voir le plan d'eau.
L'entrée principale devrait donner sur une grande place publique
afin de respecter le zonage, et ainsi de suite.
Vous voyez donc les cinq plateformes -
ces boîtes-ci - à l'intérieur de chacune se passe une chose très distincte.
L'espace entre elles crée une sorte de continuum urbain,
ces choses dont nous ne pouvons pas prédire l'évolution jusqu'au même degré.
Pour vous donner un sens de l'envergure de cette idée,
le plus grand bloc, nous l'appelons la spirale des livres.
Elle est construite de façon très peu onéreuse -
c'est un parking pour livres.
Il s'adonne à être situé du 6e au 10e étage du bâtiment,
mais cette solution n'est pas forcément coûteuse.
Elle permet d'organiser toute la classification décimale Dewey en un parcours continu.
Permettant sans problème de croître ou de se contracter à l'intérieur du bâtiment.
Elle va toujours garder cette clarté
qui mettra fin à cette espèce de voie larmoyante
que nous avons tous connue dans les bibliothèques publiques.
( Rires ).
C'était donc l'étape finale; prendre ces blocs,
que nous avions mis de guingois,
et les ancrer avec un revêtement.
Ce revêtement sert à deux choses, encore pour des raisons budgétaires.
D'abord, fournir de la stabilité latérale à toute la construction:
c'est un élément structural. Mais ses caractéristiques furent conçues non seulement pour la structure,
mais aussi pour retenir toutes les vitres.
Ces vitres furent ensuite - je vais simplement utiliser le mot 'imprégnées' -
on leur a appliqué une couche de métal qui s'appelle du métal tendu.
Ce métal agit comme une micro-persienne,
pour que, de l'extérieure du bâtiment, le soleil le voit comme totalement opaque,
alors que, de l'intérieur, c'est complètement transparent.
Alors, je vais maintenant vous faire visiter le bâtiment.
Voyons si j'arrive à le trouver. S'il y en a parmi vous qui --
qui sont sujets au mal des transports, je m'excuse.
Voici donc le bâtiment.
Et je crois que c'est important, lorsque nous avons d'abord dévoilé le bâtiment,
le public a pensé - l'a vu comme la pure expression de
nos caprices et de notre ego.
Et il fut défendu, croyez-le ou non, par les bibliothécaires. Ils ont dit:
"Ecoutez, nous ne savons pas ce que c'est, mais nous savons qu'il couvre tous nos besoins,
selon les observations
que nous avons faites concernant le programme."
Ici nous passons par l'une des entrées.
C'est donc un bâtiment inhabituel pour une bibliothèque publique,
évidemment.
Ici nous entrons dans ce que nous appelons la salle de lecture - pardon, le salon.
C'est vraiment une fonction que nous avons inventée avec la bibliothèque.
Reconnaître que les bibliothèques communales
offrent le dernier vestige d'espace libre et gratuit.
Il y a tout plein de centres commerciaux pour s'abriter de la pluie
au centre-ville de Seattle,
mais il y a beaucoup moins
d'espaces gratuits où l'on peut s'abriter de la pluie.
Nous offrons donc un espace sans protocole où les gens peuvent faire n'importe quoi,
y compris manger, hurler, jouer aux échecs et cetera.
Nous montons maintenant vers
ce que nous avons baptisé la salle de mixage.
C'était le principal local technique du bâtiment.
Il faut me le dire si je vais trop vite.
On monte.
Ici, c'est l'espace que nous avons prévu dans le bâtiment
là où je pourrais proposer le mariage à ma femme. Juste là.
( Rires ).
Elle a dit oui.
Il ne me reste que très peu de temps, alors je vais arrêter là.
Je pourrai vous montrer ceci plus tard.
Mais voyons si je peux rapidement nous amener dans la spirale des livres,
parce que je crois, je répète, la partie la plus -
voici la salle de lecture principale - la partie du bâtiment la plus singulière.
Pas encore le vertige ?
Et voilà, nous entrons dans la spirale des livres.
Bon, c'est pas évident à s'en apercevoir,
mais c'est effectivement un escalier continu.
Il permet, en se déplaçant sur un quadrilatère urbain,
de monter un étage entier. C'est donc sur un continuum.
Bon, je vais faire demi-tour maintenant pour atterrir sur un autre projet.
Je vais le parcourir très très vite.
Voilà le théâtre de Dallas. Un client inhabituel pour nous
parce qu'ils sont venus nous dire:
"Nous avons besoin de vous pour faire un bâtiment tout neuf. Nous travaillons dans
un espace provisoire depuis trente ans,
mais grâce à cette espace provisoire
nous sommes devenus une compagnie théâtrale notoire.
La scène a son vrai foyer à New York, Chicago et Seattle,
sauf l'exception de la compagnie théâtrale de Dallas."
Et ce fait même qu'ils travaillaient dans un espace provisoire
faisait que pour Beckett ils pouvaient faire sauter un mur;
ils pouvaient monter "La Cerisaie" et foncer un trou dans le sol, et cetera.
Nous nous trouvions alors devant la très décourageante tâche d'avoir à faire un bâtiment flambant neuf
qui garderait - qui serait un bâtiment 'inaltéré',
mais qui garderait ce caractère expérimental.
Et de deux, c'est ce que l'on appelle un
théâtre polyvalent: on monte
toutes sortes de spectacles venant d'un répertoire.
Le matin on fait
du théâtre-en-rond,
puis en proscenium et ainsi de suite.
Ils avaient besoin alors de passer rapidement
d'une forme d'organisation de l'espace de jeu à l'autre,
et pour des raisons d'économie des charges d'exploitation,
ceci ne se fait pratiquement plus dans la plupart
des théâtres polyvalents aux Etats-Unis.
Nous avons dû, alors, inventer un moyen de surmonter ce problème.
Nous avons décidé alors de remettre le théâtre littéralement sens dessus-dessous:
prendre les segments jusqu'alors définis comme côté public et côté scène
et les empiler - niveau public et niveau scène -
et ainsi créer ce que nous avons nommé une machine théâtrale.
Nous investissons les fonds du coté de l'exploitation du bâtiment.
On pourrait presque poser ce bâtiment n'importe où: où que vous le posez, l'espace là-dessous
est ainsi équipé pour le spectacle théâtrale.
Il nous a aussi permis un retour aux principes primaires
et une nouvelle conception des cintres, de l'enveloppe acoustique,
de l'enveloppe d'éclairage et ainsi de suite.
Au simple toucher d'un bouton, il permet au directeur artistique
de passer entre une scène en proscenium, en éperon et, vraiment,
en rond et processionnaire et jusqu'au parterre vide
par des configurations très rapides.
Nous pouvons donc effectivement aller, en utilisant le budget d'exploitation nous pouvons -
excusez-moi, le budget d'immobilisation - nous pouvons en effet faire
ce qui n'était plus faisable avec le budget d'exploitation.
Ceci veut dire que désormais le directeur artistique dispose
d'une palette d'où il ou elle peut sélectionner
entre une gamme de formes et une gamme de processions,
parce que cette enceinte autour du théâtre,
ce piège qui fige habituellement le côté public et le côté scène,
nous l'avons fait jouer.
Le directeur artistique dispose ainsi des moyens de présenter -
réaliser un spectacle qui commence par une procession wagnérienne,
comprend un premier acte sur scène en éperon,
un intermède en forme de procession grecque
un deuxième acte en arène et ainsi de suite.
Je vais vous montrer ce que - ce que ceci veut dire pratiquement.
Voici le théâtre vu de près.
Chaque segment de la paroi du théâtre peut être ouvert séparément.
L'enveloppe d'éclairage peut être relevée indépendamment
de l'enveloppe acoustique. Vous pouvez ainsi monter du Beckett
avec Dallas comme rideau de fond.
Des panneaux extérieures peuvent être ouverts pour que vous puissiez
faire entrer des motocycles en pleine scène, ou tout simplement monter un spectacle en plein air,
ou pour l'entracte.
Les balcons sont tous mobiles pour s'adapter à toutes ces configurations,
mais ils sont aussi rétractables.
La cage de scène peut aussi disparaître.
Vous pouvez faire entrer des objets énormes et, en effet, leur -
le premier spectacle de la compagnie théâtrale de Dallas -
sera une pièce sur Charles Lindbergh,
et il faudra qu'ils fassent entrer des vrais avions.
Et puis le bâtiment leur permet aussi, en dehors de la saison théâtrale,
de
louer leur local pour des évènements totalement différents.
Le voici de nuit - excusez moi, vu de loin.
Ouvrir des segments tout entiers pour toutes sortes d'évènements.
Et de nuit.
Encore, dégager l'enveloppe d'éclairage; garder l'enveloppe acoustique.
Voilà une exposition de camions gigantesques.
Je vais vous montrer maintenant le dernier projet.
Ce client-ci est également peu usuel.
Ils ont complètement inversé les principes de la promotion immobilière.
Lorsqu'ils nous ont rencontrés ils ont dit - à la différence des promoteurs communs -
ils ont dit, "Nous voulons commencer par l'idée d'offrir
un musée d'art contemporain
à Louisville. C'est notre objectif principal."
Ainsi, au lieu d'agir comme un promoteur qui ne voit que l'occasion
de faire de l'argent, ils ont compris qu'ils pourraient jouer le rôle de catalyseur
dans leur centre-ville.
Et le fait qu'ils voulaient soutenir
le musée d'art contemporain a effectivement construit leur pro forma détaillé.
Ils ont donc procédé à l'envers.
Ce même pro forma nous a menés
à construire un bâtiment hybride de taille importante
afin de satisfaire leurs aspirations concernant l'art,
mais il a aussi créé des occasions pour l'art lui-même
de collaborer, interagir, avec des espaces commerciaux;
un cadre dans lequel les artistes désirent de plus en plus fréquemment travailler.
Il a également exigé de nous de penser à comment obtenir
quelque chose qui serait et un bâtiment autonome
et un vrai composant de l'ensemble.
Maintenant je vais - voici la silhouette de Louisville -
je vais vous faire la liste
des différentes contraintes qui ont donné son expression au projet.
Les contraintes physiques d'abord. Nous avons dû en effet intervenir
sur trois chantiers séparés,
tous beaucoup, beaucoup plus petits que l'empreinte réelle du bâtiment.
Nous avons dû intervenir à coté du nouveau centre Muhammad Ali
tout en le respectant.
Nous avons dû intervenir à l'intérieure de la zone inondable de la crue centennale.
Déjà, cette zone est inondée trois à quatre fois par an
et il y a une levée derrière notre chantier
similaire à celles qui ont cédé à la Nouvelle Orléans.
Nous devons intervenir derrière l'axe I-64,
une rue qui passe entre les trois sites.
Alors ces - nous commençons à fabriquer une espèce de
cauchemar de contraintes dans une baignoire.
Sous la baignoire se trouve
le réseau principal d'électricité de la ville.
Et puis on a voulu ajouter un parcours piétonnier
entre une série d'édifices d'intérêt culturel,
et une perspective - puisque c'est le quartier historique -
qu'ils ne voulaient pas gêner avec ce nouveau bâtiment.
( Rires )
Et maintenant nous allons ajouter 100.000, 00 mètres carrés.
Et si nous avions fait dans le traditionnel, ces 100.000, 00 mètres carrés -
voilà les différents programmes - traditionnellement on identifierait
les éléments publics, et les disposerait sur des sites,
et se trouverait dans une situation abominable:
un aménagement public planté dans une baignoire qui déborde.
Ensuite on calibrerait tous les autres éléments -
les éléments commerciaux variés:
hôtel, logements de luxe, bureaux et ainsi de suite -
et tout ficher là-dessus. Et nous aurions créer quelque chose
d'impraticable.
En effet - et vous le savez - cela s'appelle l'édifice Time Warner.
( Rires )
Notre stratégie était alors très simple.
Juste relever le bloc tout entier,
basculer certains éléments, les pousser un peu
pour leur donner la perspective et la juxtaposition désirées par rapport au centre-ville,
créer des accès piétonniers et faire dévier la route.
C'est donc le concept de base,
et je vais maintenant vous montrer où on en aboutit.
D'accord, on dirait un geste très stylisé, voire têtu,
mais il découle directement de ses contraintes.
Et, encore une fois, lorsque nous l'avons dévoilé, nous avons constater une certaine crainte
que l'on avait affaire à un architecte qui voulait signer son manifeste,
et non pas à un architecte qui voulait résoudre
une série de problèmes.
Bon, à l'intérieur de cette zone centrale, comme j'ai dit,
nous avons la possibilité de mélanger plein de choses.
Vous voyez ici que ces -
cette - on dirait une radiographie - les tours
sont entièrement conçues selon le cahier des charges des promoteurs. Ils nous ont précisé les dimensions, les volumes et cetera
et nous avons focalisé sur le regroupement de tous les composants publics -
les halls, les bars,
tout ce qui appartiendrait aux éléments commerciaux -
leur regroupement au milieu, dans ce genre de plan du Métro,
dans l'échangeur qui comprendrait aussi le musée d'art contemporain.
Il en résulte une situation comme celle-ci,
où vous avez des artistes qui peuvent opérer dans
un espace d'art au vingt-deuxième étage comprenant aussi une vue imprenable,
mais elle dispose aussi d'une proximité que le conservateur
peut décloisonner ou non.
Elle permet que les sportifs sur leurs vélo d'appartement
soient vus, ou puissent voir l'art, et ainsi de suite.
Elle fait aussi que si un artiste veut coloniser une piscine, par exemple,
il peut ouvrir son exposition dans la piscine.
Il n'est pas obligé à toujours travailler dans les limites
du plan de la galerie contemporaine.
Comment construire cela alors ?
C'est très simple: c'est une chaise.
Nous commençons donc par construire les noyaux.
Au fur et mesure que nous construisons les noyaux, nous construisons le musée d'art au niveau du sol,
ce qui permet une efficacité et une rentabilité incroyables.
Ce n'est pas un bâtiment à gros budget.
Dès que les noyaux arrivent au niveau central,
nous terminons le musée d'art, nous y installons tout l'équipement mécanique
et puis nous le soulevons au vérin.
On construit les grands hangars par cette méthode,
ceux que l'on a fait pour le A380 par exemple.
Terminer les noyaux, terminer la chair,
et vous avez un objet comme ceci.
Il ne me reste maintenant environ 30 secondes, alors je voudrais démarrer
un film d'animation, et nous allons clore avec ça.
( Applaudissements )
Chris m'a demandé d'ajouter -
que le théâtre est en construction, et
la construction de ce projet-ci va débuter d'ici un an à peu près,
et terminer en 2010.